à l'évidence à 10h 12h et là aujourd'hui
je suis assez bien c'était quoi je suis
en train entrant un travail mais tu l'as
déjà bien tu l'avais déjà vue avant de
savoir conduire enfin que je veux le
voir et je suis heureux voilà
aujourd'hui c'est ma journée
l'ec145 démarque du lot reconnaître qu'à
un bien pour un poster dédicacé de se
jeter à la mer morte mettre le feu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bérard était coupé gt le groupe c est ce
que voulait la surprise du protectorat
ou well as tu fait défaut n'est pas égal
[Applaudissements]
ces propos montrent la nationalité du
col de la cité comme a été avec nous
vous avez une chance qu'on leur impose
voilà une analyse des selles alors hd
nos pôles métiers là je vais n'aura bien
aimé nouailhas blanc il ya mémoire
j'adore moss mais c'est les mêmes motifs
c'est quoi terrain voilà c'est un masque
soutien
oui c'est un masque c'est mon cas cela
dit cette fois castaldi il peut le
mettre ailleurs partie ne touche pas à
mon poste le jeu j'ai pris ça bêle
morini-bosc comme personnage voilà si
j'ai bien envie de jouer envie thoune
jeu voir si je suis bon comme quelques
chroniques et on n'était pas aux côtés
de sébastien cauet dans la méthode cauet
sur tf1
cartman bruno guillon cécile de ménibus
micro aussi quel est le nombre de
participants atteints par le candidat
prénommé paul participation quelques
j'apprenne à lire en fin de semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
à